My chapter on theisms versions of
Heaven,
I sloped the idea.
I probably won't be accepted by
evangelicals and fundamentalists,
but you know,
when Jesus talked about the kingdom is
within a images,
there's not as,
not as often as I would've liked,
but I think he's referring to the fact
that habit is within us in the sense
that we should be aiming to improve
ourselves.
And you know,
that Christians and atheists of
conflicted over this passage where he
says,
uh,
you know,
Matthew Sixteen,
Twenty six,
I say unto you,
there are some standing here which will
not taste death until they see the son
of man coming in his kingdom.
And,
you know,
of course atheist,
go,
ha,
he's still not here.
Uh,
but,
but what if he meant something else that
heaven is not a place to go,
but a way to be
here.
And now I'm very,
I'm very,
what would you call a viewpoint that I
think is very much worth pursuing?
I would also.
But I also think there's something
deeply strange about that too because,
um,
I think that if a psychological state
becomes profound enough,
it starts to become a social state.
And so I would say that that,
that Kingdom of God that's within,
which is something tolstoy wrote a lot
about,
by the way,
that was a book that he wrote,
a book called the Kingdom of God is
within us and that profoundly influenced
Mahatma Gandhi by the way.
And they had lengthy correspondence
which was part of the reason that Gandhi
became a non
use nonviolent resistance right in his
fight against the English,
which was quite interesting.
But I think that there is,
there is there look something like this,
maybe when you go to a concert,
it's a great concert and you're having a
very profound psychological experience
of,
of unity and harmony,
which of course is what you get into
concert.
But if the experience is profound enough
psychologically and individually,
it also starts to encompass and envelop
the people around you.
And so I think the Kingdom of God that
Christ was talking about with something
like this is why I like jumped piaget so
much.
It's something like the and equilibrated
state where things are working out
really well for you when you're deeply
immersed in a meaningful experience,
but at the same time that meaning is
structured so that it's maximally
beneficial for the people who are
immediately around you and for the
people who are distantly related to you.
And so everything stacks up and some
that's some.
That's something like the idea of the
ladder to have under the stairway to
heaven,
did everything stacking up properly and
then there's an.
There is.
See,
I think when people experience that,
and this is where the metaphysics
touches the material.
I think that when people.
Yes,
exactly that precisely got yes.
Precisely that.
Well,
did you notice that the demons are
upside down going down,
right?
Which is exactly right.
That's exactly the right way to
conceptualize it.
So I think that when people have an
experience of that stacking of meaning,
that they also have an intimation of
immortality that goes along with that.
That's embodied and that that's partly
why they're metaphysical speculations
about the reality of the Kingdom of
Heaven.
There'll be merged because it's not just
conceptual right there.
There is embodied experience and people
report the same thing when they have
transcendental experiences of various
sorts and those,
and we know from a scientific
perspective that those can be very
reliably induced with the use of agents
like psilocybin.